I love you I love you I love you so much
you're so pretty
oh such great energy and you like food
line well we have lunch right after this
well go ahead let's go girl would you
bring everything to eat I'll get
whatever you want
I just Buddha lead only desi at this
point uh except for onions I don't like
your name you don't like Ron you know I
like garlic I like garlic too
there you go have some garlic yeah you
were so good in this film so much fun
and the fact that you kick ass like in
Everly you did this all over again do
you have fun at in action movies I had a
lot of fun in this way yeah I had a lot
anyways you know easy breezy yeah not I
just I only have a couple of scenes but
she is just delicious to be delicious to
be her if your husband just a little bit
scared of you I thought he would be he's
the only person that was not surprised
that was their dog area which made me
question myself yeah it's insane how
much I enjoyed later and how how easy he
took it like I yeah it's like any other
choosing yeah and you curse so well it's
so it just comes out of you like what's
your favorite curse word to go to I like
my curse words in Spanish she's okay so
give me one okay what
yes I just worried about you said it's
so seriously I did that the fact is that
it was really wet okay
yeah you got a girl I'll write it down
oh my god never you see maybe I can
become the Mexican Sam Jackson no we
know his favorite or you know you say
the word and he's nobody does it better
but maybe I can be the chena be like we
had again and I got another scene yeah
no look at me that way my mom or my mom
oh my goodness
sorry was supposedly trump asked you out
if he were to ask you out again who
would you want to be your bodyguard
family or or going to ask me to say the
bad word now when you want to be your
body guy Ryan or Sam Sam and I can both
bring them both yes yes enough talking
about food I love your Instagram Allah
following you at that picture of you and
that corset and you're saying how if you
love food you don't have to learn how
you have to learn how to suck it in and
we're talking about food like so what is
your all-time favorite food and I French
Indian Thai Japanese Chinese Italian
absolutely Mexican Spanish food Cory and
I've learned the whole world through
their spices and love food